[Music]
I realized from my time on the homestead
that being a part of where you Source
your food is one of the greatest things
you can do with your time and I had so
much more respect for just a single
tomato
because I knew how much time how much
care and how much love I was putting
into all of my plants this soil feels
great
it's like so spongy thank you we've been
working really hard on the soil health
so it's so nice when someone sees it
appreciates that
it's the off season for Melissa's Garden
but I can tell she knows all of the
tricks to get the most out of her soil
this is the berry patch so our Autumn
bearing raspberries they start producing
fruit August September October until we
get our really hard Frost then these
ones start in June for The Raspberries
so I have fresh raspberries coming on
all the way from June through October so
you're having berries pretty much all
year long pretty much all you're amazing
I feel like that's the key to
homesteading yeah
Melissa has this gardening thing down to
a science she knows exactly how to get
berries all year long by planting
different species
I can also see how rich all her garden
soil is but none of it would be possible
without fertilizer and for that she
needs her chickens oh the chickens are
excited to see us coming because I have
not let them out yet
hi chicks
as soon as I walk over to the chicken
coop I realize it's unlike any I've ever
seen I love that you have this chicken
tractor on Wheels the wheels are great
so this is just nice because it gives us
both the protection of the chicken
tractor and directing where I want their
manure for our pasture Health but then I
can also let them out so these were like
often old broken down riding lawnmower
that didn't work anymore so as long as
the bearings are good like grab those
Wheels there are so many things you can
do with it so great and then it keeps it
in that closed system feeling where
you're just able to upcycle things that
you already have so you can bring your
chickens all over the homestead they
till things up with their feet and then
they add in their chicken poop that as
we notice just so great could I see this
thing moving I want to see it enough
yeah absolutely an ATV is a home
sitter's best friend awesome
this mobile Chicken Coop idea could be a
game changer for Will and Grace
wow that's so perfect that makes moving
your chickens around so much easier
that's so cool I love it
no wonder Melissa's crops are so
abundant she can put the chickens right
where she wants them to nurture the soil
I always like to make sure that I've got
enough manure for the springtime
planting and we're actually seed
starting those I love seeds we love
seeds yeah yeah let's go check them out
[Music]
thank you